et oui c'est l'édito économique de la
matinale bonjour jean marc sylvestre
bonjour à vous merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
ce qui est assez étonnant jean-marc
c'est que cette crise pandémique a coupé
le monde de l'économie en deux il y à
une france qui pleure et qui a beaucoup
de difficultés et puis il y à une france
qui va très bien et qui se frotte les
mains expliqué nous tout ça qui va bien
oui c'est vrai vous avez raison c'est
assez étonnant
je reviens l'alliance sur les chiffres
de la consommation en décembre
ils ont créé la surprise parce que ils
sont bons ils sont bons plus de 4% par
rapport à l'année dernière où il avait
pas de crise à ce pays
ça prouve qu'il a du ressort il a des
moyens il lui manque peut-être un peu de
confiance même beaucoup de confiance
parce que en amont de cette consommation
bien c'est là que les choses ne vont pas
bien alors c'est vrai il ya une france
qui est très optimiste actuellement n'en
parle pas beaucoup mais elle se compose
principalement des dirigeants des
grandes entreprises multinationales
pourquoi pas parce que ces entreprises
là elle travaille elle travaille
essentiellement à l'étranger et que sur
les marchés étrangers
eh bien on s'est un peu réveillé par
avec des prévisions qui sont plutôt
bonnes si on regarde l'eau c d e le fmi
le marché chinois est reparti assez fort
et le marché américain ne souffre pas
trop
en dépit des difficultés sanitaires les
grandes entreprises françaises
s'attendent donc à un rebond assez fort
dans les mois qui viennent d'où leurs
projets d'investissement la seule
incertitude c'est qu'elles ont du mal à
créer des emplois et notamment des
emplois en france
alors à côté de ces grandes entreprises
vous avez toutes les entreprises elles
sont nombreuses du secteur digital
c'est à dire les fabricants de systèmes
de logiciels parce que la crise a
accéléré la mutation digitale de
l'ensemble du sud de l'économie alors
les entreprises n'étaient pas prêtes au
moment du premier confinement elles en
ont tiré les leçons
donc on aura une année exceptionnelle
pour les entreprises du digital
en termes de chiffres d'affaires en
investissement et même beaucoup en
création d'emplois qui sont des emplois
évidemment assez spécialisés dans ces
secteurs là le digital va faire une
croissance à deux chiffres alors ya
d'autres secteurs à côté du digital qui
tirent leur est pas
du jeu l'agroalimentaire les entreprises
de santé ce qui est intéressant c'est
que toutes ces entreprises là qui voit
la vie en rose reconnaissent que
l'exécutif a été très réactif avec
notamment les plans garantis par l'état
les prêts et puis les allocations
chômage partiel donc ces entreprises ont
accepté tous ces parachutes là mais
finalement elles n'ont pas à lui à les
ouvrir c'est plutôt ça la bonne nouvelle
mais jean-marc à côté de cette france
qui va bien il ya une réalité ont une
france qui va mal qui va même très mal
oui alors c'est une autre façade de la
réalité elle va très mal absolument il
ya beaucoup de souffrance
beaucoup de créer beaucoup de pleurs et
vous avez une france économique qui ne
voit pas comment rebondir dans les
petits commerces dans les cafés
restaurants les hôtels le tourisme le
transport aérien enfin on les connaît
ces secteurs vous avez en gros presque
un million d'entreprises qui sont dans
la panade qui sont dans une situation
même désastreuse alors vous avez d'abord
quelques grandes entreprises qui était
malade avant la crise air france
renault était malade avant la crise les
chantiers navals et dont on peut se
demander s'il faudra continuer à leur
fournir des béquilles très coûteuse
après la crise ensuite vous avez
beaucoup de petites entreprises qui sont
en panne faute de trésorerie à cause de
toutes ces procédures de confinement ou
de restrictions d'ouverture et non plus
de clients donc elle non plus cible à
faire donc elle ne fonctionne pas ces
entreprises là sont étouffés
appartiennent à des secteurs de
l'hôtellerie du tourisme de
l'événementiel de la culture les salles
de cinéma quand le propriétaire des
salles de cinéma genre comment vous
pouvez faire votre votre fin de mois
puis vous avez tous les cafés
restaurants alors le drame de beaucoup
de ces entreprises c'est qu'elles ne
savent pas comment s'adapter aux
nouvelles habitudes qui ont été prises
par leurs clients
il ya la situation actuelle bien sûr
qu'il faut gérer et l'état déziel à
gérer ça il ya du chômage partiel
il ya des moratoire sur le paiement des
charges il ya des moratoires qu'on est
en train de négocier sur le paiement des
loyers mais elle se demande comment
elles vont s'adapter à la nouvelle donne
le télétravail par exemple va changer
beaucoup d'habitude dans des quartiers
très très très peuplée par pas parler
par les bureaux par par les sièges
sociaux
vous avez beaucoup
beaucoup moins de gens qui viennent
travailler donc vous allez tous les
restaurants autour qui se dit et bien on
pourra plaire comme pas continuer de
travailler le tourisme d'affaires par
exemple va se tarir on va abandonner
on a déjà évidemment contraint et forcé
à abandonner certaines pratiques de
voyager au bout du monde pour des
séminaires d'entreprises dont l'utilité
n'est pas évidente mais il est
vraisemblable que cette habitude là eh
bien on va on va la garder on va pouvoir
continuer de travailler en
visioconférence le cinéma est ce qu'on
retournera demain ou au cinéma alors
qu'on sait tous précipités sur netflix
il ya des réformes structurelles qui
vont toucher un certain nombre de
secteurs et que ces secteurs vont avoir
du mal à se redresser
que peut faire le gouvernement je
remarque face à ces entreprises
justement là croyez-moi c'est évidemment
la hantise du ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire le déconfinement ne
résoudra pas ce problème qui est un
problème structurel vous beaucoup de ces
entreprises avec déjà des aides avant et
deux mains et maël vont avoir besoin
encore des loups alors de réformes
structurelles et les réformes
structurelles mais ça coûte très cher en
emploi
la crise va révéler des difficultés
qu'on n'avait pas voulu voir à voir on
avait mieux à tous chers sous le tapis
mais là ça apparaît vous savez il ya un
grand financier américain warren buffett
qui a une phrase terrible il dit vous
savez quand la mer se retire à marée
basse
eh bien on voit tous ceux qui ont perdu
leur maillot de bain ou même qui qui
sont en difficultés avec la crise ça va
être un peu la même chose et ça concerne
pas mal de secteurs
le problème posé ne sera pas seulement
financier dans ce cas là parce que de la
finance on en trouve toujours
aujourd'hui avec de la dette mais ça va
être politique
merci beaucoup jean-marc je rappelle on
vous retrouve tous les mercredis matin
dans la matinale de rtl france pour
votre éclairage économique